lleno de rumores y resentimientos desde
la salida de las tropas rusas hace un
mes el único momento en que la población
se reúne es en la entrega de las
pensiones sino todo el mundo se queda en
casa con puertas cerradas todavía hay
muchos colaboradores aquí si pudiera
pondría la mitad del pueblo en la cárcel
el objeto de todas las acusaciones esta
pareja de agricultores ante los ojos de
sus vecinos recibió a los soldados rusos
en su casa los entrevistamos con una
discreta cámara
con nosotros Nunca fueron amenazantes
hablamos con ellos les dimos comida una
vez y volvieron decían que su jefe solo
les daba pan duro Así que mi esposa les
hizo pasteles
eran niños tenía mucho pesar con ellos
alrededor de gerson hay cuentas
pendientes donde empieza la colaboración
un dolor de cabeza legislativo en esta
pesada atmósfera de una sospecha
generalizada comienzan las
investigaciones llamado a registrar el
edificio ocupado durante siete meses por
las fuerzas rusas el equipo de la
Fiscalía de gerson Busca pruebas un
cocinero Ucrania no ayudó a los soldados
en este desorden informantes vinieron a
entregar información cada pequeño
detalle cuenta recogemos huellas el ADN
una colilla o un bastoncillo de algodón
pueden decirlo si los ucranianos han
elegido el campo enemigo y ayudarlos a
identificarlos los traidores deben ser
castigados la justicia ha abierto 18.000
expedientes por presunta colaboración
investigaciones delicadas la justicia
ucraniana sigue siendo bastante